en este vídeo retaremos a nuestro
cerebro porque vamos a repasar el tema
de las divisiones recordemos las partes
de una división dividendo divisor
cociente y residuo
también podemos representar a la
división de la siguiente forma
para que una división sea correcta el
residuo debe de ser menor al divisor si
tienes un residuo mayor al divisor tu
operación estará mal vamos a empezar
imaginemos a un grupo de tres amigos
carlos teresa y juan que van a la tienda
a comprar videojuegos cada videojuego
cuesta 300 pesos pero cada uno de ellos
tiene una cantidad de dinero diferente
la cantidad de dinero que tiene cada uno
es el dividendo el cual representaremos
con la letra x por el momento y los 300
pesos que cuesta cada videojuego es el
divisor entonces veamos cuántos
videojuegos puede comprar cada uno
carlos solo tiene 500 pesos por lo que
hay que dividir sus 500 entre los 300
pesos que cuesta el videojuego el
resultado es que carlos puede comprar
solo uno y le restan 200 pesos por otro
lado teresa ahorró 800 pesos entonces el
planteamiento es 800 entre 300 ella se
podrá comprar dos videojuegos y
200 juan tiene 1.100 pesos entonces
puede comprar tres juegos 1100 entre 300
es igual a 3 y restan 200 te has fijado
que a los 3 les sobran 200 pesos por qué
crees que pasó esto pausa el vídeo e
intenta descifrar por qué cuando tengan
la respuesta reproduce el vídeo para
saber si acertaste
muy bien como te pudiste dar cuenta el
dividendo que se refiere al dinero que
llevaba cada uno de los tres amigos se
incrementó exactamente lo que cuesta un
juego o sea el divisor por eso cada uno
de ellos pudo comprar un videojuego más
que la anterior es decir el cociente
aumentó de uno en uno te invito a que
sigas practicando